bonjour à tous bienvenue sur passé
sauvage je suis cludite chamusi et
aujourd'hui je réponds à toutes vos
questions oui en effet il y a quelques
temps je me suis rendu compte que la
seule vidéo de ce type qui existe sur la
chaîne remonte à il y a plus de 6 ans
donc il y a plein de nouveaux plein de
nouvelles par ici bienvenue si vous
venez de d'arriver là aujourd'hui sur la
chaîne n'hésitez pas à vous abonner à
activer la cloche il y a plein de vidéos
qui vont arriver dans les prochaines
semaines notamment les derniers épisodes
de la saison de mission archo pour
clôturer cette saison 1 de mission archo
j'aimerais bien avoir des fois un lieu
qui me permettrait de documenter
d'enregistrer de me souvenir en fait de
de ces moments de tournage qui ont
vraiment été des moments hyper joyeux
pour moi c'est c'est un moment de ma
carrière qui est vraiment super sur tous
les plans et pourquoi pas faire un site
web mission archo où je pourrais mettre
des photos de tournag des anecdotes de
tourn AG mettre évidemment tous les
épisodes en lien et pour ça je vais
utiliser un outil qui s'appelle Odou
pour faire le site web mission archo
Odou sponsorise la vidéo du jour je vous
présente leur leur outil et on enchaîne
après avec la FAQ Odou est un outil
hyper pratique pour créer votre site et
leur première application est gratuite
pour démarrer vous cochez simplement une
application par exemple moi je choisis
site web et cette fonctionnalité là
restera gratuite à vie donc je crée le
site mission archeo d'ailleurs les noms
de domaine sont personnalisables si vous
le souhaitez et la première année vous
est offerte et voilà vous pouvez dansz
déjà personnaliser votre site donc moi
j'ajoute des photos des tournages je
mets les liens des épisodes qui sont
disponibles et bientôt ils le seront
tous et je peux voir aussi ce que ça
rend sur sur smartphone et ça c'est très
pratique c'est vraiment très simple à
prendre en main vous glissez des
éléments sur la page et ensuite vous les
modifiez à l'envie sur Odou
l'hébergement et le support sont
gratuits en illimité c'est vraiment
parfait même si vous êtes une petite
entreprise parce qu'il y a notamment des
fonctionnalités des applications de
facturation qui vont vous faire gagner
un temps assez précieux donc voilà merci
à Odou d'avoir sponsorisé la vidéo vous
pouvez retrouver le lien dans la barre
d'info qui vous permet d'essayer cet
outil et on enchaîne avec les questions
alors les questions je les ai pas euh je
les ai pas lu j'ai pas réfléchi à la
réponse que j'allais donner parce que
j'estime que ce genre de format
euh le but c'est que ce soit spontané
que vous voyez un petit peu mon mon
caractère à travers ma manière de
répondre aux questions enfin si vous
voulez vraiment voir mon découvrir mon
vrai caractère je vous invite à aller
sur twitch les mercredi soir ou les
lundis matin tu es ce genre de personne
imprévisible si elle ne boit pas son
café non mais c'est c'està-dire que
quand on fait les tournages mission
archo voà c'est c'est
terminé mais euh quand l'équipe
d'archéologue ne nous propose pas un
café à 10h et qu'on s'est levé à 6 je ne
pense qu'à ça je ne c'est c'est c'est ah
Anthony Gibert me demande tes vieilles
pierres préférées à Lyon ou dans
l'exagone en général alors là ce qui me
vient en premier je dois dire que c'est
le
mégalitisme breton le morbillant les
premières fois que j'ai découvert ça
finalement il y a bah à l'ouverture de
la chaîne il y a un peu un peu moins de
10 ans c'est Lucas qui m'a emmené sur
ces ces terr là parce qu'il a vécu en
Bretagne et il m'a fait découvrir voilà
loc mariaaker Gavrinis et puis
évidemment bah c'est un endroit où on a
appris à fouiller ces périodes là
notamment le néolithique avec Philippe
Gouzin que j'embrasse il passe par ici
et qui nous aue accueilli sur son
chantier pour l'épisode 2 de mission
archo vraiment c'est des c'est des
structures c'est des environnements qui
me touchent vraiment parce que parce
qu'on peut pas vraiment les comprendre
parce que ça parle de rides funéraire et
que on doit on doit admettre qu'on est
qu'on est ignorant face à à enfin 50 %
ignorant face à ces à ces construction
et qui a que l'archéologie qui pourra
peut-être nous apporter quelques
quelques
détails sur sur la manière de faire de
nos ancêtres et là on remonte à
plusieurs millénaires donc voilà c'est
ça qui me qui me vient en premier quand
est-ce que vous allez faire des vidéos
sur les Étrusques ah cette civilisation
préromaine en Italie toscanon brillacium
vous pourriez même faire un voyage
d'Odyssée en Italie sur les différents
sites étrusques mais c'est une très
bonne idée ça vous savez que l'Odyssée
c'est vraiment ce qui a un peu fait
découvrir la chaîne à plein de personnes
d'entre vous des fois quand certains
d'entre vous m'arrêtent dans la rue
c'est pour cette série donc et c'est
enfin elle a été faite tellement avec
peu de moyens avec peu de ressources bah
c'était là ce que j'ai en face de moi un
trépied une caméra un microcanon c'est
tout et évidemment bah il y a le travail
de Christophe Fournier qui est venu
apporter toute cette ambiance poétique
évidemment que j'aimerais faire une
suite à l'Odyssée dans une autre autre
contrée euh j'avais pensé à la Turquie
mais l'Italie ce serait génial mais si
on devait refaire une saison 2 de cette
série il faut des moyens financiers ça
coûte très cher parce qu'il faut payer
toutes les autorisations pour filmer sur
les sites et donc ça me fait le lien
avec euh ta question sur les Étrusques
il se trouve qu'il y a un an euh on a
voyagé non il y a un peu moins d'un an
on est allé justement se faire un tour
avec Lucas sur les sites archéologiques
étrusques donc au nord de Rome le lac de
Bolsena tout ça j'ai beaucoup filmé mais
je n'en ferai rien de ces rushes en tout
cas j'en ferai rien à titre euh public
parce que je n'ai pas les autorisations
il est vraiment possible de faire du
super documentaire un peu comme on a
fait pour le mur d'Adrien mais c'est une
très bonne idée que je garde en tête
vraiment mais ouais parce que les
Étrusques
il y aurait tellement à faire encore une
fois avec de l'illustration quelque
chose pour essayer de d'approcher un peu
cette culture ce serait super je vous
mets quelques images des photos de ce
qu'on a filmé notamment la nécropole de
serveterie si vous avez l'occasion
d'aller là-bas allez-y enfin là quand la
question d'avant les vieilles pierre qui
me touche le plus si c'était pas en
France c'est un des plus bel endroits
que j'ai visité agès GC quel est ton
objet c'était sur Facebook ça c'estes
questions quel est ton objet ou tes
objets archéologiques préférés oh ouh là
là mais il y en a trop mais comment
répondre alors ça va tu es sympa parce
que tu m'as dit tes objets le premier
truc qui me vient là si on pense
évidemment euh allez objets riches
objets qui qui qui sont voilà dans un
matériau précieux c'est le torque en or
de la sépulture de la dame de Vix parce
que j'ai eu l'immense chance de voir
l'original et non pas uniquement la
copie qui est au musée de Châtillon sur
scène le musée du trésor de Vix donc
c'est une on en a parlé sur cette chaîne
de la tombe de la dame de Vic je vous
mets le lien de cette vidéo dans le
petit i c'est une vidéo qui vous
présente plein de sépulture de femm de
l'âge du bronze en Europe et évidemment
la dame de Vic c'est un peu le le c'est
la plus connue parce que c'est la plus
riche j'ai eu la chance de voir
l'original quand j'ai travaillé avec
national geographique j'ai fait un
documentaire il y a un an un peu plus
d'un an avec national géographique sur
les femmes préhistoriques et c'était
préhistoire au sens large he chronologie
très très large puisqu'on s'arrêtait on
allait jusqu'à cette sépulture l'équipe
du Musée avait été incroyable nous avvez
très bien accueilli et nous avvez montré
vous avez sorti des réserves le torque
original qui est un donc un torque pour
ceux qui ne savent pas c'est un un bijou
c'est une parure qui sert vraiment à
montrer la la richesse de la personne
qui la porte qui a été porté de son
vivant visiblement parce que les
cervicales de de cette femme était
extrêmement abîmé faut imaginer donc un
énorme anneau en or avec deux boutons en
orord aux deux extrémités le travail
d'orfèvrerie sur cet objet est
incroyable il est tellement incroyable
que alors je sais pas si c'est une
légende mais c'est ce qu'on nous a dit
au musée que
les les artisans de l'école BOULE donc
qui qui est une école très très reconnue
en en France n'arrive pas à imiter
parfaitement le travail qui a été fait
pour sur cet objet c'est-à-dire vous
avez un espèce de fil d'or qui est qui
n'est jamais interrompu et qui vient
décorer notamment les deux boutons dorés
vous avez des pégases alé enfin c'est
vraiment une merveille un autre objet du
coup là un petit peu moins euh un peu
moins facile à citer parce que il est il
est moins précieux mais moi il me touche
beaucoup c'est quelque chose que j'ai vu
oui je bois mon café pendant cette efq
excusez-moi pour les les misophones pour
mission archo 2 on a tourné en Corse et
on a fait le musée de la préhistoire de
Corse je sais plus où il se trouve je
vous remettrai pare les infos dans la
barre de description et à la fin de la
période néolithique il y avait une
petite tête en argile façonnée je vous
mets la photo la photo parle d'elle-même
je trouve ça incroyable et d'ailleurs
Thomas Perin qui nous a accueilli et qui
participe à l'épisode nous a dit
attention là ce truc c'est le c'est le
truc le plus c'est l'objet le plus fou
du musée selon lui hein c'était
subjectif mais moi je suis d'accord et
c'est vrai que depuis cette tête là je
l'ai pas oublié enfin je trouve ça
incroyable de de trouver ça quoi quelque
chose qui je sais pas on arrive à
imaginer un petit peu la la personne qui
a façonné ça pour son pour son plaisir
on dirait un peu une une marionnette et
quelque chose de très très caricatural
dans dans dans dans l'expression de ce
ce visage voilà ça c'est un objet qui
m'a vraiment touché là cette année on a
découvert avec Lucin on n'était jamais
allé on est beaucoup allé au musée
Guimet à Paris qui est le musée des de
l'archéologie asiatique et des Art
asiatique c'est un musée mais c'est un
musée incroyable j' tellement travailler
avec eux si passe par là n'hésitez pas
non vraiment parce que vous êtes
accueilliis par des statues en pierre
grise gigantesques qui vont jusqu'au
plafond enfin vraiment ça vous ça vous
écrase presque et il y a l'étage Chine
néolithique mais il y a des trucs mais
les gars mais allez-y allez-y allez
juste faire au moins cette partie làà il
y a des objets en jade en forme de de
tigre c'est d'une beauté c'est c'est
c'est une technicité pour arriver à à
maîtriser la pierre à ce à ce point
allez-y et puis sinon évidemment vous le
savez mon musée préféré de tous les
musées c'est le musée d'anthropologie de
Mexico voilà bah tous les objets qui
sont au musée archéologique de de Mexico
c'est tout après le livre des projets
dans les cartons hors YouTube ou c'est
trop tôt alors merci Louis deson en
cours donc le livre que j'ai pris avec
moi nous venons de sortir en octobre ce
livre avec Lucas Pacotte qui est donc
une compilation d'histoire vraie de
l'antiquité donc vous avez César et la
césarienne les thermopiles versingetorix
évidemment les éléphants de guerre
d'Hannibal pierus la bibliothèque
d'Alexandrie Diogène voilà je vais très
très vite Sibel Isis Mitra les nouveaux
dieux orientaux pitea c'est ce qu'il a
découvert l'Islande ce mec et c'est
vraiment des tout petits chapitres voilà
et que vous pouvez picorer vous êtes pas
obligé de commencer par le début c'est
pas dans l'ordre chronologique c'est
pour ça c'est fait exprès et donc
d'autres projets et ben il y a d'autres
livres nous sortons en 202
4 3 livres non quatre alors je sais ça
fait beaucoup et ça fait beaucoup en
même temps mais c'est comme ça c'est pas
forcément ce qu'on ce qu'on a prévu sort
un très très bel essai sur le climat
donc ça c'est un petit peu le gros
projet de 2024 j'en ai beaucoup parlé
sur Instagram ensuite il y aura un album
jeunesse sur les animaux de la
préhistoire l'illustrateur qui est éic
feres qui est un illustrateur incroyable
mais allez le suivre sur Instagram et
vous verrez donc les premières planche
de cet album jeunesse dans l'année 2024
voilà il y a trois nouveaux livres
quatre quatre qui
sortent sur Youtube maintenant vous
m'avez demandé poil au divant merci pour
ton superbe travail merci beaucoup quels
sont les projets futurs pour la chaîne
contenu et ou direction les futurs
projets bah c'est évidemment à côté des
livres la saison 2 de mission archeo qui
fera C épisodes au lieu de SEP mais
évidemment il y aura une quelque chose
de nouveau quelque chose qui une
histoire qui sera à suivre dans chaque
épisode c'est
incroable faire
absolument c'est une saison en plus où
on a pu filmer à l'étranger notamment il
y a un épisode qu'on a tourné en Croatie
voilà on a on a voyagé un petit peu dans
pour cette saison Manu best of plus
incroyable ce pseudo [__] mais vous me
faites
oh respect pourquoi s'être lancé sur
Youtube et à quoi tu carbure pour
continuer le
café je bois beaucoup de café j'adore le
café c'est dire que à part quand il est
15h c'est la limite que je me fixe pour
le café bah je suis triste et là ceux
qui sont sur twitch disent oui mais
après il y a une autre boisson qui
arrive à partir
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
19h santé messieurs dames ah TRV c'est
pas mal à consommer avec modération tout
tout est à consommer avec modération
pourquoi mêtre lancé sur Youtube et bien
mais ça j'avais déjà répondu sur sur
dans la première FAQ j'ai un parcours
universitaire classique j'ai commencé
avec une licence en histoire de l'art et
archéologie et puis j'ai enchaîné avec
un master recherche en archéologie je me
suis spécialisée dans l'archéologie
sous-marine en étudiant notamment la
navigation antique en Méditerranée après
ce master évidemment j'ai essayé de
faire une thèse mais comme j'ai vu que
j'avais jamais all avoir de financement
B en fait je me suis autorisée à faire
quelque chose que j'avais envie de faire
et moi depuis le lycée j'ai envie de
faire du documentaire j'ai eu la chance
de faire un lycée avec une option cinéma
audiovisuel ça a été une révélation pour
moi de de découvrir certains films de
découvrir ce travail-là et donc bah j'ai
voulu lier les deux je me suis dit ok
mon terrain c'est l'archéologie c'est ma
formation mais euh ce qui me fait le
plus kiffer c'est de filmer c'est de
faire du montage du documentaire donc
évidemment bah d'où ma joie de faire
mission archo vous le comprenez et j'ai
tenté ça parce que j'ai vu que on était
en 2016 il y avait très peu de femmes
sur YouTube et il y avait c'est toujours
le cas il y a pas beaucoup de
documentairire donc voilà moi je creuse
ce lieulà et je me suis lancé voilà
parce que ça me faisait plaisir parce
que je je j'avais envie de faire ça
j'avais envie de faire du documentaire
d'archéologie juju
mouliad me demande bonjour j'espère que
ça va ça va ma question est quelles sont
tes croyances mythologiques préféré
euh elle est cette question pour moi
elle est dur cette question parce que je
suis pas fan de la mythologie fa être
tout à fait honnête la mythologie n'est
pas quelque chose qui me qui me touche
j'aime les histoires vrai et c'est pour
ça qu'on a sorti ce bouquin je trouve
que la mythologie est une est un moyen
de s'intéresser à l'histoire à
l'archéologie c'est un moyen
némotechnique l'idée que je me fais de
la mythologie vous vous l'avez dans le
dernier épisode d'Odyssée sauvage qui a
été tourné sur le M Olympe pareil je
vous le mets dans le petit i j'adore la
mythologie
mais j'ai du mal à répondre à cette
question vous avez vu comme je galère
là je trouve qu'on en fait grand cas et
que d'autres histoires réelles sont bien
plus alléchantes je moi je suis je sais
qu'il y a deux écoles notamment pour ce
qu'on regarde les films et compagnie moi
j'aime le réalisme euh je n'aime pas
aller dans une dans une dimension trop
éloignée de la ré c'est pour ça que je
suis pas très touché par la
science-fiction donc c'est pour ça que
je suis pas hyper touchée par la
mythologie voilà mais donc s'il faut
répondre à cette question quelles sont
tes croyances mythologiques préférées
comme c'est dur je crois que celle qui
m'intéresse le plus parce que je n'y
pour le coup je n'y connais rien bah on
parla du je parlais du musée guillemets
tout à l'heure la
mythologie asiatique finalement ce qu'on
voit sur les basreliefs à
angangcor pour moi c'est incompr
coméhensible c'est c'est un exotisme pur
pour pour une occidentale du 21e siècle
ça m'a fait la même chose quand on
visite le Templo Maor
ou Theo tiwakan au Mexique ce qu'on voit
les les scènes qui sont représentées
sculptées sur les bâtiments elles sont
incompréhensibles pour nous parce que
c'est une mythologie qui nous est
totalement étrangère c'est quelque chose
qui m'intéresse voilà c'est quelque
chose qui me qui me spte et même quand
je me documente là-dessus il y avait eu
des su émissions là-dessus sur France
Culture et ben même au terme de ces ces
émissions bah je reste encore
complètement
ignorante sur ces questions là et ça ça
me ça me bouscule ça me touche et et et
donc ça marque un intérêt pour pour ces
croyances là est-ce qu'il y aura
d'autres vidéos découvertes dans
d'autres pays comme le site de aloua en
Arabie Saoudite aloua c'est un déjà faut
dire ce que c'est c'est une commande on
nous a commandé cette vidéo on a été
payé pour pour faire ce documentaire on
aimerait énormément retourner là-bas
parce qu'en fait c'est c'est un site qui
est en train d'être mise en tourisme
quand on y allé il était pas encore
ouvert donc je vous je vous raconte même
pas le la chance immense que c'est pour
des des des gens euh qui sont issus de
l'archéologie et qui font du
documentaire de pouvoir filmer des sites
bah qui sont sans sans tourisme en fait
qui sont vides donc on aimerait
énormément mais ça ça ça vient pas de
nous il faut que ce soit des commandes
et euh et on a plusieurs propositions on
a des propositions pour aller filmer en
Alaska au Liban au Gabon en Éthiopie bon
quand quand ce sera possible d'aller
là-bas c'est des propositions qui
viennent des chercheurs des archéologues
mais eux n'ont pas les les financements
donc en fait c'est toujours une question
de tune comment on paye les gens comment
nous on se paye pour aller filmer dans
des endroits bah c'est des journées
d'intermittence quand euh on est avec
euh Julien Lucas ils sont intermittents
du spectacle voilà il y a des il y a des
tarifs de base qu'on peut pas renier euh
nous c'est pareil Lucas en tant
qu'auteur il faut le payer donc voilà il
faut des enveloppes d'argent et dès
qu'on a dès qu'on arrive à réunir cet
argent bah oui on part filmer et on fait
et on fait une vidéo tu habites quel
quartier de Lyon j'emménage en septembre
on se rencontre
euh j'habite à Lyon voilà une ville que
j'adore j'ai débarqué ici à 19 ans j'ai
fait bah toute ma vie d'adulte je
j'adore cette ville mais en même temps
quand quand on a des théâtres antique à
porté de main un quartier Renaissance
pareil à 5 minutes à pied on va pas se
mentir c'est surtout parce qu'à
terraadlice je suis très contente de
vivre à Lyon et et de ne pas avoir euh
de ne pas être allée à Paris je suis
très contente de ne pas avoir eu ce
cette crainte que si je ne vis pas à
Paris je n'auraai pas de travail je je
n'auraai pas tout le réseau bon j'ai une
qualité de vie qui est super à Lyon et
par contre je me déplace tout le temps
je vais tout le temps à Paris mais voilà
c'est un équilibre que j'ai trouvé et
que je compte bien maintenir encore de
nombreuses années en tout cas le plus
longtemps possible ensuite y a-t-il des
lieux que tu aimerais visiter pour des
missions archo mais qui sont trop loin
ou trop cher bah ça rejoint un peu ce
qu'on a dit avant évidemment l'Arabie
Saoudite c'est incroyable euh moi
j'adorerais filmer au Mexique très cher
trop cher par rapport à ce que le CNC
peut nous peut nous offrir
comme comme comme aide voilà les les les
aides du CNC elles sont plafonnées à
30000 € et avec 30000 € faire une série
à l'étranger c'est un peu limite donc
après peut-être que ça fait partie aussi
de l'évolution de la chaîne réussir à
aller trouver d'autres financements
peut-être des financements du plus
classique hein des financements de de la
région voilà on verra mais faut ça faut
que j'apprenne à le faire j'ai que j'ai
que quelques années de d'expérience en
production de de de séries et de
documentaires donc voilà j'apprends
petit à petit la
Capart ça c'est notre team langost alors
si vous ne comprenez pas les langostes
c'est c'est ceux qui nous suivent sur
twitch voilà nous sommes la team langost
pourquoi parce que j'ai un don j'ai un
don quand je suis dans un parking quand
je suis dans du souterrain je sais
m'orienter voilà et apparemment les les
langous
ont ce pouvoir de savoir revenir à leur
base où qu'ell se trouve voilà sans être
à l'extérieur forcément voyez bon c'est
un délire voilà mais si vous voulez
mieux comprendre c'est sur c'est sur
twitch que ça se passe une de nos
langostes me demande la recette magique
du ginto et du Homar pareil le ginto si
vous ne savez pas bah c'est c'est nos
c'est nos soirées twitch donc la recette
magique B il y a pas c'est pas magique
c'est pas de la mythologie le ginto
c'est bien réel et ça nous aide et ça
c'est important sugar ting encore une de
nos langostesouou est-ce que vous avez
des éléments à nous partager sur votre
prochain livre donc notre prochain livre
euh ce sera un livre sur le climat donc
ce sera de la
paléoclimatologie le climat mais il y a
bah il y a des des centaines de milliers
d'années hein pour essayer de comprendre
ce qui se passe aujourd'hui on a eu des
très bons retours de l'éditeur donc on
est hyper bien accompagné on est trop
content de comment eux déjà l'ont reçu
ça va être bien c'est juste que ça ça va
être super bien voilà ah bah schougar tu
me poses une autre question est-ce que
tu vas participer à des conférences des
talk show ou des events du genre
prochainement c'est en cours de
discussion mais normalement en 2024 je
devrais faire une petite conférence pas
vous dire où ni quand comment parce que
c'est pas encore officiel c'est des
choses que j'adore faire les conférences
je me souviens que les conférences que
j'avais pu donner au festival Les
historique de notabéné à Montbazon ça
fait partie de mes meilleurs souvenirs
de toutes ces années de YouTube j'adore
ça j' adore le l'ambiance l'échange
qu'il y a entre vous et moi sur une
scène voilà ce cette pression que ça met
ce stress que que j'adore j'adore ce
stress prè conférence Léa en passant du
terrain à la vulga est-ce que le fait de
participer au fouill ne te manque pas
pas du tout les amis ah non mais pas du
tout même j'ai un j'ai un plaisir assez
terrible à filmer les gens filmer les
archéologues qui en bavent me me procure
une certaine une certaine joie hein je
me dis ah la vache je ne suis plus à
cette place j'ai adoré je suis hyper
contente d'avoir bossé d'avoir eu ce
travail physique euh de mes 20 25 ans un
peu après encore mais non ça me manque
pas parce que c'est vraiment un travail
qui
est faire de la pioche toute la journée
c'est c'est é unant c'est très
intéressant aussi mais il y a un côté un
peu parfois il y a des journées qui sont
un peu abrutissantes hein faut faut faut
être bien clair avec ça quand vous avez
que pioché tout seul dans votre coin
toute la journée et que vous sa que vous
allez vous allez faire la même chose le
lendemain et le lendemain et pendant 3
semaine ouais c'est un
peu c'est un peu dur quoi et puis c'est
surtout que c'est hyper précaire en fait
maintenant je sais que les boîtes
privées comme archodunom embauchent
énormément voilà le le le marché du
travail c'est rouvert et tant mieux mais
moi je suis vraiment passée à une époque
où il y avait pas de boulot et voilà
c'était c'était c'était un peu déprimant
donc non ça me ça me manque pas du tout
et puis en plus voilà il faut aussi
savoir ce qui nous convient je suis très
heureuse maintenant c'est c'est
maintenant que je je kiffe ma life que
je fais des projets que j'aurais jamais
imaginé réussir à faire donc ce qui fait
que ça peut pas me manquer ce que j'ai
laissé ne me manque pas et d'ailleurs je
vois pas du tout ça comme un abandon je
vois ça comme une une
continuité une réorientation mais je
vois bien que j'ai évolué en fait je je
suis en train vraiment de de me trouver
d'être à mon endroit et et tant que je
suis heureuse ben je pense que les les
choix ont été bien bien fait et bien
pensé pour moi mais c'est une très bonne
question merci de l'avoir posé qu'est-ce
qui te passionne le plus dans ton métier
c'est bien cette question et j'aime bien
ce que le mot passion apparaisse parce
que souvent justement quand j'étais sur
les terrains les chantiers à chaque fois
CIT c'est quelque chose qui revient
souvent c'est les les gens se rendent
bien compte des visiteurs par exemple
des gens qui visitent le site voilà
disent ah là là c'est dur mais vous avez
la passion donc comme
si ce motl passion permettait de de de
supporter bah des choses qui sont qui
sont difficiles à supporter moi c'est
vrai que le enfin la fouille archo il y
avait pas vraiment c'était pas vrai il y
avait pas vraiment de passion je le
faisais parce qu'il fallait que je me
forme ça faisait partie de ma formation
fallait bien je pouvais pas être juste
archéologue de bibliothèque il fallait
Fall que j'ai ce ce cette technique sur
le terrain que je sache manier ses
outils mais je suis pas passionné de la
pioche je suis pas passionné du taacyo
je suis pas passionné de de la truelle
enfin c'est c'est c'est c'est pas vrai
la passion elle est plutôt voilà dans
dans le travail de synthèse ok une fois
passé le moment de la fouille il y a la
post fouille où là on essaie de bah de
de d'assembler un puzzle ça c'est
passionnant mais ça vient après et
souvent quand vous êtes étudiant
technicien de fouille c'est pas votre
partie c'est pas ça que vous faites en
revanche maintenant la passion euh
oui elle est présente dans mon métier ce
qui me passionne le
plus c'est ce qui se passe sur le sur le
tournage quand on fait l'émission
archo parce que je demande moi c'est
c'est moi qui réalise je demande à ce
qu'on filme beaucoup je demande à ce que
les caméras ne s'éteignent quasiment pas
donc il y a Lucas de Levau qui a la
caméra principale qui fait les
interviews qui qui voilà c'est la caméra
une et moi j'ai toujours ma caméra aussi
ou bah dès que je suis pas en interview
ou en échange avec un archéologue je
filme également et moi ce qui me
passionne le plus c'est d'attendre le
moment où il va y avoir soit un accident
qui arrive dans le un accident personne
se blesse mais quelque chose qui est
imprévu moi ce qui me passionne dans mon
métier c'est de capturer l'imprévisible
et de travailler avec cette cette
improvisation qui me passionne c'est
aussi le
montage moi j'adore voir que en fait
j'ai pas une liberté totale en montage
le ce qu'on a filmé et ben il y a une
ambiance les gens qu'on a filmé ils ont
un caractère ils ont une attitude ils
ont une manière d'être à l'image qui
qu'il faut comprendre et ça donne la
tonalité d'un épisode ça ça me passionne
parce que une fois que j'ai compris
quelle est
l'émotion majeur de cet épisode et ben
là tout commence à se mettre en place
dans ma tête un exemple précis c'est par
exemple l'épisode 2 de mission archo
donc tourner en Bretagne sur des
structures funéraires du Néolithique et
de du Bronze Ancien la séquence finale
de cet épisode pour ceux qui l'ont vu
c'est le levage d'une Stelle
anthropomorphe qui va être placé qui va
partir du site et moi je me souviens que
pendant le tournage me su la vache il y
a quelque chose de comment dire de
funéraire un peu on dirait un
enterrement j'avais la musique de de de
Chopin dans la tête parfois je je j'ai
des musiques qui me viennent quand on
tourne et ça quand ça arrive quand je
sais au moment du tournage que c'est
c'est ça c'est cette émotion là qu'il
faut que je mémorise et il faut que
j'arrive à la retranscrire dans le
montage c'est ça qui me passionne dans
mon dans mon métier l'autre chose qui me
passionne dans mon boulot c'est la
collaboration que je peux faire avec
d'autres artistes notamment avec David a
pour tous les FASTCAM que vous avez vu
cette année c'est passionnant de
découvrir des des des des visions qu'ils
ont eux et qui mettent sur papier et
après il y a le motion design le travail
qu'il a fait pour la la vidéo des crânes
et des vautours les symboles du
néoliiquees ça m'a tellement touché ça a
été mon fond d'écran pendant les 6
derniers mois il nous a fait une
magnifique un magnifique cadeau pour
clôturer ce travail avec Lucas il nous a
offert une illustration qui me fait un
peu penser au musée guillemets je vous
la je vous l'affiche là rapidement
regardez ça c'est mais quel cadeau enfin
voilà ça ça me passionne de travailler
avec des gens qui ont une telle
créativité une telle un tel talent ça a
été pareil avec Christophe Fournier
quand on a bossé sur l'odysée enfin
cette vidéo va être longue les amis hein
oh là là cCZ quel regard portes-tu sur
l'évolution de ton travail bah je suis
hyper fière franchement et et après je
sais que je suis je suis pas toute seule
et que j'ai eu énormément d'aide alors
là Lucas est-ce qu'on peut le remercier
ici il a toujours été un d'un soutien
fou et et là je suis hyper fière cette
année
de de réussir à à tenir dire les choses
comme elles sont financièrement à
trouver des financements pour embaucher
payer l'équipe qui m'entoure ça c'est
une grande fierté c'est un grand stress
aussi de pas savoir comment on va payer
les gens dans les 6 prochains mois et si
bah du coup on devra retourner à un
format toute seule et et et je suis
vraiment étonné aussi de ce que j'arrive
à faire VI a ce truc aussi me dire bah
en fait c'est possible c'est possible de
sortir plusieurs documentaires dans une
année j'ai un regard très doux aussi sur
mon mon travail je je sais que j'ai pas
eu une une ascension fulgurante sur
Youtube c'est pas vrai la la chaîne
voilà elle a évolué petit à petit de
manière très régulière et elle a pas eu
des grands hauts ou des grands bas et ça
c'est ma plus grande victoire parce que
j'ai évidemment qu'on on aimerait tous
faire un million de vues sur Youtube
pour chaque vidéo et encore je pense que
ça amène une ambiance qui est qui est
assez étrange et que du coup on contrôle
plus mais là moi enfin mon autre mon
autre bonheur c'est pas une fierté c'est
un bonheur bah c'est de vous avoir en
fait mais quelle communauté j'ai là sur
sur cette chaîne enfin j'ai des échanges
incroyables avec plein plein d'entre
vous j'ai plein de vos pseudos en tête
chaque jour parce que bah vous êtes avec
moi tous les jours je sais pas à quoi
vous ressemblez je vous ai jamais croisé
euh mais quand même on est en
lien constant toutes les semaines
j'échange avec vous donc et ça d'avoir
d'avoir ça c'est c'est hyper chaleureux
je sais pas j'ai l'impression vous êtes
un un grand poncho pour moi et les vous
sa ah est-ce que vous savez que j'ai une
passion pour les
poncho j'ai une passion pour les poncho
si cette communauté est un grand poncho
on peut dire que c'est que que c'est
plutôt pas mal vraiment merci de votre
présence non mais vraiment je queles
sont sont vos rêves et vos
projets c'est bien cette question des
rêves voyez évidemment mais il y a des
projets qui ne voient pas le jour parce
que j'ai pas forcément la la technique
et le savoir pour les mener à bien donc
il reste dans des cartons un projet sur
l'alimentation je travaille dessus
depuis depuis 4 ans et bah il peut pas
se faire pour l'instant mais je
l'abandonne pas pour autant simplement
il est dans un carton et peut-être qu'un
jour j'arriverai à le faire c'est un
documentaire long c'est du 50 minutes et
j'arrive pas à le faire produire ça
m'intéresse personne pour l'instant bah
mon autre rêve c'est juste que ça
continue là l'année qui est passé sur
passé sauvage mais si ça pouvait être
toutes les années pareil alors je sais
que c'est pas possible enfin qu' y a
forcément du changement et de
l'imprévisible mais vous imaginez cette
année enfin la chance j'ai j'ai pu
produire une série documentaire formalon
une série classique face caméra avec de
l'illustration pensée pour créer pour de
la création pure et euh des projets de
livres avec des super maisons d'édition
qui vont arriver c'est un rêve bah c'est
un rêve ta civilisation période préférée
me demande slevenen Wolf 9751 waouh euh
c'est dur bah oh là là il m'est
difficile de ne pas aller à Rome une
fois par an donc est-ce que Rome antique
voilà est-ce que c'est c'est c'est c'est
là que ça se situe ma préférence mais
quand même l'Amérique latine c'est
quelque chose qui moi me je comprends
pas cet endroit enfin qui c'est fou quoi
ce qu'ils ont fait quand on pense le
Pérou on en parle du Pérou j'ai le
ventre qui gargouille [__] j'ai la
dalle on va bien c'est bientôt à la fin
de la vidéo ah les Mayas les Mayas mais
pardon mais le le le matin où on a
débarqué à palenk avec Lucas on a été
silencieux on sa'est tu on ne sait pas
parler pendant toute la visite lui il
s'est mis dans un coin avec un carnet il
a fait un dessin moi j'ai pris des
photos et j'ai profité du
moment c'était c'était c'était
incroyable mais après il y a pas besoin
de voyager très très loin pour être
complètement émerveillé par par ce qu'on
voit hein voilà moi ce que je vois en
Bretagne Gavrinis lock mariaaker Carnac
ça me bah pareil il faut que j'y aille
une fois par an et et je profite quand
je suis là-bas je trouve ça merveilleux
j'ai pas de civilisation préférée mais
euh là où je vais régulièrement bah oui
c'est Rome cette ville c'est ma ville
préférée j'adorerais j'adorerais vivre
un an à Rome ça ce serait ah ouais le
rêve le rêve ce serait d'avoir une
résidence dans la villa micis et de
pouvoir vivre à Rome 1 an ça c'est un
rêve voilà je ne sais pas si ça se
produira on verra je crois qu'on a fini
les amis je crois qu'on a je crois que
j'ai répondu à grande majorité de vos
questions je vous remercie énormément de
m'avoir posé ces questions en tout cas
j'ai j'ai passé un excellent moment
à avec vous à répondre à vos questions
là vous allez voir cette vidéo en
décembre mais donc merci pour cette
année vous avez été incroyable vous vous
m'avez laissé des commentaires vous
savez des fois je prends des captures
écran de vos commentaires parce que vous
êtes d'une gentillesse infinie c'est un
soutien vous êtes vraiment vous êtes un
pon de chaud voilà vous êtes meslangou
je vraiment je vous aime j'espère
vraiment pouvoir en rencontrer certains
d'entre vous lors des dédicaces
puisqu'il y a des livres bah souvent il
y a des dédicaces j'en ai rencontré
certains d'entre vous pour ce bouquin là
que vous pouvez commander dans toutes
les bonnes librairies et en ligne
évidemment je vous retrouve la semaine
prochaine dans en commentaire pour le
mission Archos 6 qui se déroule à
alisia c'est c'est assez incroyable
c'était c'était c'était super je clôture
ici je vous remercie d'avoir regardé
cette vidéo j'espère que ça vous a plu
j'espère que vous avez passé un bon
moment je vous embrasse et je vous dis à
très vite salut
[Musique]
c'est dans la boîte